Maribeth is with us in North Carolina hi
Mary Beth have Merry Christmas to you
Merry Christmas thank you very much um
so my question is my mother my mom she
sold a house in another country my
husband told her that she needed to like
buy another house within about a year
because of capital gains taxes but she
didn't do that she instead gave it to us
and then we bought a house we invested
in the house and so now she's getting
letters from the IRS saying that she's
going to be fined but I my question is
who's supposed to report it up or her
it's not income to you she has a gift
tax on it and I don't know if she sells
a house in another country does she live
in the United States yeah she was in the
US no yeah okay I'm not sure capital
gains applies to not sure how capital
gains laws apply to a foreign home to
property exactly you'd have to see a tax
advisor on that I do know that you can't
give one hundred thousand dollars to
another person without intake without
getting gift tax or if you didn't make a
couple of moves I mean there's a couple
things you could have done it's after
the fact now how long ago was this four
years
oh lord I know I know she's probably
gonna get hammered with taxes she needs
to go see a professional tax advisor now
if someone wants to give another person
one hundred thousand dollars you can
file under the unified gift tax unified
estate tax form that allows you to use
up part of your estate tax exemption as
a gift and she could have done that and
had zero taxes on it if she'd 'simply
done one piece of paper with her tax
filing that year I don't know if she can
go back for years and file an amended
return and put that in there or not
hopefully she can and that way it'll be
that simple to get rid of it if she
doesn't it may cost her 20 or third
thousand dollars okay so you don't think
it falls on our shoulders it's not on
your shoulders at all okay
Eris is not contacting you they're
contacting her yeah okay and she may or
may not have capital gains do you on the
sale of that property and she will have
gift tax due on giving away a hundred
thousand dollars to when it's not given
to a certified charity which are
obviously not and without using the
unified estate tax credit which you can
do it's not that big a deal unless you
have a huge estate you're doing detailed
planning but but I mean it's not really
not so have her jump on the website at
Dave Ramsey comm and get in touch with
one of our tax professionals hopefully
one of them can go back and file an
amended return and get this off of her
and they should also be able to advise
her whether she has actual capital gains
do you on the sale of that property or
not I don't know about that just because
you profit a hundred thousand or you get
a hundred thousand into your hands
doesn't mean you have a taxable gain
necessarily she could have paid down
them you know the mortgage and sold the
property for what she actually bought it
for in which case she would have had no
gain but could have put a hundred
thousand in her hand
and so just because she got money in her
hand at the closing does not necessarily
mean she made a profit on the property
gain is profit and that's what the
question is there so ever touch bases
while the taxi lp's at Dave Ramsey comm
and in her area and they should be able
to walk her through it there's two
different issues the capital gains on
the sale of the property and whether or
not and then the gift tax can I'm an
amended return be filed back for years
to do away with that gift tax problem
ouch